you were a kid who no one expected to go
into music you really didn't have any
formal musical training i mean
not at all i like to write i mean in
high school i wrote um poetry i wrote
poetry and i wrote uh parodies of uh
movies and had my family and friends
and we also made movies like day after
the night of living dead right so i like
to write
nonsense stuff were you the leader of
the b52s would you say
well i
i probably helped spur us to start a
group because i was living in atlanta
and we were all friends from years
before this is a whole crew of people
who live in atlanta athens georgia
athens georgia and i was visiting and we
went to a restaurant uh
we couldn't afford uh food so we had
drinks and then it was great we went to
a friend's house and he stayed upstairs
and wrote letters and we went downstairs
and he had a set up for a group and we
just came up with killer bees because
killer bees had just arrived in brazil
but wait a second so you start writing
and stuff and you meet these other
people who sort of are creative and yeah
they are into writing music and hanging
out and someone says hey let's start a
band and then you hear about the killer
bees so we say we'll name ourselves
b-52s or no keith had a
we um we just started jamming and
friends of mine were having a
valentine's day party and i said oh i'm
in a band they go and i said you want us
to play for it and they said sure so i
went back to the others i said do y'all
want to do a show
and they said sure and then we realized
we didn't have a name so keith came up
with b-52s basically the hairdo based on
hairdos which look like nose cones and
jets and stuff so when you start to get
famous what was your first big hit was
it was rock loft rock lobster all of a
sudden big hit it became like a really
independent it was our first independent
single and it did do well for an
independent single with no promotion and
john lennon himself said he was inspired
to start recording music again after he
heard rock lobster yes
um he was in a dance club and he heard
it yeah he liked he liked
the beat and how crazy was and then
uh when cindy does that
uh ah
you know wild vocal
[Music]
you know that's inspired definitely
inspired by yoko and um
i think something registered you know
you know
he said yoko it's time you know and
they went ahead and did yeah
you